en total se necesitan 29.95 mili litros
de ácido clorhídrico 1.25 molar para
alcanzar el punto de equivalencia
calcula la concentración de sorbato de
potasio a los corchetes significan
concentración en la solución madre ok
recordemos cuál es el punto de
equivalencia mire el punto de
equivalencia es el punto en el que todo
el sorbato de potasio ha reaccionado con
el ácido entonces lo que tenemos es
justamente el lado derecho de la
ecuación iónica net y otra forma de
verlo es como el punto en el que bueno
por cada molde sorbato de potasio que
queremos convertir en ácido sórbico
necesitamos agregar un molde de ácido
clorhídrico entonces una forma de
entender el punto de equivalencia es que
si agregamos un cierto número de moles
de ácido clorhídrico eso debe ser igual
exactamente el mismo número de moles de
sorbato de potasio que tenemos
inicialmente es decir agregamos
exactamente el mismo número de moléculas
de ácido clorhídrico que agregamos
originalmente de sorbato de potasio para
que se puedan cancelar entre sí entonces
sí podemos saber el número de moles del
ácido clorhídrico
podríamos decir bueno si necesitamos ese
número de moles de ácido clorhídrico
para alcanzar el punto de equivalencia
eso significa que la solución original
tiene el mismo número de moles de
sorbato de potasio y así podremos usar
eso para calcular la concentración
entonces hagamos la primera parte
calculemos cuántos moles de ácido
clorhídrico tenemos aquí entonces para
el hc l
hc l vamos a ver si tenemos 29.95
mililitros
vamos a convertir esto en litros porque
la concentración que tenemos está dada
en términos de molar y that y acuérdense
que esto es igual a moles / litros hay
que asegurarnos de que nuestras unidades
sean consistentes ok entonces vamos a
multiplicar esto por para convertir esto
a litros necesitamos multiplicar por
algo que tenga litros en el numerador y
mililitros en el denominador
así los mililitros se cancelan y sabemos
que un litro es igual a mil mililitros
entonces esto nos dará la cantidad de
ácido clorhídrico que agregamos en
litros y ahora vamos a ver a cuántos
moles equivale esto así que vamos a
multiplicar por la concentración
entonces por 1.25 y en lugar de escribir
solamente molar con una m mayúscula
vamos a poner 1.25 moles
entre litros
y esto a que es igual bueno usemos la
calculadora tenemos 29.95 entre 1000 que
tenemos aquí por 1.25 y esto es igual a
vamos a ver aquí tenemos tres cifras
significativas y aquí tenemos cuatro
entonces para el resultado vamos a dejar
solamente tres esto es igual a cero
punto cero 374 eso es igual a cero punto
cero 374 y como las unidades son
consistentes los mililitros se cancelan
con mililitros los litros se cancelan
con litros y así nos quedan
0.0 374 moles recuerden estos son los
moles de ácido clorhídrico entonces
cuando nos dicen que usaron 29.95
mililitros en total de una solución de
ácido clorhídrico
1.25 molar en realidad están agregando
este número de moles de ácido
clorhídrico y eso significa que nuestra
solución madre tiene este mismo número
de moles de sorbato de potasio y si él
sorbato de potasio tiene el mismo número
de moles ya podemos calcular la
concentración original
entonces la concentración del sorbato de
potasio 66 h 72 es igual a el número de
moles de sorbato de potasio que ya
dijimos que es igual a este número de
moles 0.0 374 moles entre cuál era el
volumen de la solución original
vamos a ver
un estudiante titula 45.00 aquí tenemos
cuatro cifras significativas
el estudiante titula 45 mililitros de
esa solución de la solución madre
entonces el volumen de la solución
original es de 45 mililitros y 45
mililitros si los queremos en términos
de litros porque recuerden que la
concentración que queremos calcular es
la concentración molar que está dada en
moles / litros
entonces 45 mililitros es lo mismo que
0.0 45 litros y si queremos podemos
escribir los 20 litros y esto es igual a
bueno aquí sólo dividía esto entre mil
por eso es que 45 mililitros es lo mismo
que 0.0 45 litros
entonces vamos a ver podemos usar este
número que ya tenemos y vamos a
dividirlo en 30 puntos 0 45 y no voy a
poner los otros ceros porque en la
calculadora no es necesario y esto es
igual a ok cuántas cifras significativas
queremos bueno estamos usando tres
cifras significativas entonces es igual
a cero punto 832 0.8 cientos 32 esto es
igual a cero punto 832 moles / litro o
también podemos decir 0 punto 832 molar
está bien
83 sí ahí está esa es la concentración
inicial del sorbato de potasio en
nuestra solución madre